[Musica]
sempre bello tornerà a vasto è sempre
bello ricevere reazioni calorose cosa
che per esempio non è successo ieri
quando raccontavo a mia zia ornella che
oggi avrei partecipato a questa
conferenza mezzi ornella di cosa devi
parlare
l'ho detto sai zia è un evento in cui si
deve dire qualcosa di che di aspirazione
delle persone che sia motivazionale un
evento il cui tema è il re mare quindi
sai lo sa e l'anno da qui stiamo uscendo
se si parla di ri partenza si farà
bisogna avere un certo spirito per per
la cosa che devo fare domani e asia mi
fa è perché hanno chiamato proprio te
effettivamente mia zia come tutte le
persone più vicine a me hanno reagito
proprio in questa maniera alla notizia
che avrei partecipato a tre dx vasto non
hanno torto nel senso che credo di
essere effettivamente la persona meno
adatta a fare questa cosa fantastica che
stiamo facendo oggi tutti qui insieme
sono una persona meno adatta perché
obiettivamente non sono affatto capace
di motivare nessuno i colleghi mi
chiamano in studio cassandra mi chiamano
a lavorare soltanto quando vogliono una
storia che sia spietata i miei amici mi
chiedono consigli soltanto quando
vogliono deprimersi o ricevere una
carezza con il guanto chiodato
in più ho questa anzi alla prestazione
congenita che mi conduce pur avendo
parlato altre diverse volte nella mia
vita in pubblico ad avere un terrore
infinito del parlare in pubblico che
gestisco
con grande dispendio di energie di
conseguenza
diciamo che non dovesse qui sulla carta
nella pratica ci sono perché ed hicks
vasto cosa fa diviene questa bella idea
gennaio di invitarmi a parlare per
motivare delle persone ma soprattutto
cosa faccio io accetto
accetto e tremendamente passo i sei mesi
successivi al mio aver accettato questa
partecipazione un po pentendo bene un po
insomma figurando me lo scenario
peggiore mi racconto questa storia dico
va bene benissimo lorenza hai detto di
sì a partecipare al 3 dic
sei la persona più pessimista
dell'universo ti toccherà mentire tu vai
lì
e dice una serie di favolose bugie come
se tanto brava a fare il mio mestiere un
mestiere creativo di conseguenza sono
molto abituato le bugie a mostrare
perlomeno la parte del successo del
delle cose più pishin tillan t che
facciamo a nascondere un po di più la
fatica ho personalmente non tanto
faticano comunque comunque arrivo qui
dico mentirò anche perché il tema è
remare io non sono assolutamente in
grado di consigliare a nessuno come
farlo in più la situazione stessa è per
me qualcosa di impossibile e quindi
rimane di cosa rimane quando cosa cosa
mai di rho
succederà che farò una figura barbina e
che è che mentirò dire inventerò
qualcosa mentirò anche perché se dovessi
essere sincera andrelli a raccontare che
mentre tutti quanti qui re mano
energicamente io in realtà
mi sento sul materassino sgonfio allargo
vicino agli scogli con la il sale nelle
lenti a contatto che so già che mi
toccherà farmela a nuoto
quindi insomma questo è quello che mi
racconto per sei mesi da quando vengo
invitata ad oggi e come reagiscono le
persone che mi conoscono questa mia
questa mia narrazione per così dire non
esattamente positiva della giornata di
oggi
reagiscono ovviamente motivando mi e
quindi compreso mia zia ornella e quindi
non ho lorenzo sarai bravissima ma tu
hai già parlato in pubblico ai
tantissime cose da dire sarai
originalissima non ti preoccupare perché
devi essere sempre così negativa andrà
tutto bene
ecco per esempio anche a loro ho dovuto
mentire perché li ringraziamo per
l'incoraggiamento grazie per farmi così
vicino crepi il lupo eccetera
internamente pensavo
lasciatemi stare pensavo bollate mi io
mi devo raccontare questa storia
tremenda fino all'ultimo minuto
non mi piace essere motivata mi piace mi
piace raccontarmi le storie tremende
perché mira scontro e storie tremende le
storie da sempre hanno un'unica funzione
per le persone e questa funzione è
quella di prepararci alla realtà quando
noi leggiamo una storia ascoltiamo una
storia
guardiamo una storia ci sono infiniti
infiniti modi di fruire di una storia
facciamo facciamo qualcosa che ci dà
grande soddisfazione cioè viviamo
un'altra esperienza che non appartiene
alla nostra realtà ma che in qualche
modo ci fa provare una versione per così
dire demo questa cosa la facciamo da
sempre
per fortuna c'è stato il professor
gardini prima di me che vi era scontato
un po di cosa come funzionava
nell'antica grecia ma questa cosa la
facciamo da dai tempi delle caverne
l'abbiamo fatta
fino all'altro ieri quando abbiamo
inventato il cinema facciamo adesso in
ogni minuto delle nostre vite quando
condividiamo qualsiasi cosa sui social
ci sono sempre più modi per raccontare
sempre più storie per raccontarle sempre
di più sempre più velocemente
abbiamo tanta fame di storie proprio
come personale sole ci piacciono ci
servono ci danno un enorme soddisfazione
questo proprio per il per il processo
che mi spiegavo prima attraverso una
storia noi possiamo fare un'esperienza
prova di quello che magari potremmo
trovarci ad affrontare in seguito nella
vita senza però il rischio di di viverla
davvero quindi il nostro immedesimarci è
sufficiente a darci quella sensazione di
conquista di un emozione di una
situazione difficile di un
di un nuovo livello successivo senza
però esporci a dei rischi effettivi e
qualcuno chiama catarsi questa questo
processo è effettivamente qualcosa di
magnifico più la storia è difficile più
ci sentiamo soddisfatti quando arriviamo
alla fine è il motivo per cui da piccoli
ci piaceva tanto quando ci raccontavano
cappuccetto rosso c'era questo clan e
max incredibile fino ad arrivare alla
frase per mangiarti meglio
ecco quando quando ascoltiamo
cappuccetto rosso ci piace tantissimo
ascoltare la frase per mangiarti meglio
perché ci piace da morire quel pezzo di
cappuccetto perché proprio lì che noi
proviamo paura ed è lì che cominciano a
domandarci si accende qualcosa che
cominciano a domandarci bene io sono lì
dentro
cosa faccio cosa succede adesso qui sono
in pericolo cosa come ciò comincia a
muoversi tutta una serie di ingranaggi
nella testa e cominciamo a trovare delle
soluzioni seppur immaginate simboliche a
delle situazioni che
in realtà
potremmo potremmo vivere anche nella
vita ci piace lo spaventarci nelle
storie perché sappiamo che ci toccherà a
spaventarci nella vita è una storia ci
fa ci fa sentire più preparati a questo
al netto di tutti i rischi che non
corriamo e sono importantissime le
storie hanno questo potere incredibile
io ci credo molto nella vita mi mi
occupo di storie le scrivo le disegno
più che scriverle a volte ma soprattutto
mele racconto faccio un sacco di auto
fiction
cos'è che succede adesso con le storie
in questo particolare momento del mondo
della società di tutti noi
succede che
ha tanta importanza il finale è da
particolare da particolare importanza
soprattutto se è un finale positivo cioè
si tende a desiderare questo dalle
storie arrivano alla fine e dimmi che
andrà bene ecco c'è la parte della
complicazione in una storia che è
vissuta come negativa come qualcosa di
cui sbarazzarsi più presto possibile
qualcosa da risolvere subito non ci
piace sentire la parte difficile delle
storie non ci piace ma ci piace ci piace
nelle storie perché non ci riguardano ci
dimentichiamo momentaneamente che ci
piacciono le difficoltà anche nella vita
perché poi le superiamo ma soprattutto
ci piace appunto raccontarcele e
superare questo momento di difficoltà
nelle storie
io oggi volevo parlare proprio di questo
di quanto è importante la parte della
complicazione in una storia se non
succede niente una storia non è
interessante ci deve essere un inizio
deve succedere qualcosa di complicato
meglio se spaventoso meglio se tragico
meglio e deve e tutto questo deve
risolversi
e questo che ci dà soddisfazione e credo
tantissimo nella funzione creativa della
complicazione
questo in tutte le storie in quelle che
racconto in quelle che
e che mi racconto e se non ci fosse la
parte della complicazione
se il lupo non si fosse mangiato
cappuccetto non sarebbe mai arrivato il
cacciatore a pensarlo e soprattutto non
l'avrebbero mai riempito di sassi per
vendetta tutto questo serve a
a darci una simbologia che ci che ci dia
soddisfazione che ristabilisca un
equilibrio e così così faccio ogni
giorno così ho fatto
per questa occasione mela sono
raccontata il più tragicamente possibile
cerco di cerco di raccontarmi la
particolarmente difficile un po per ogni
cosa e devo dire che come allenamento
funziona abbastanza mi ha risolto
diversi problemi in passato e
soprattutto mi piace essere preparata
sempre al peggio
non credo che questo significhi essere
negativi come mi dice meteor nell credo
che questo significhi essere disposti ad
attrezzarsi e credo soprattutto che la
letteratura le storie siano uno dei
migliori modi per farlo
leggere e
e magari anche anche scrivere anche
scrivere per se stessi e mettere
mettere per iscritto le proprie paure
approfondirle esplorarle andare in fondo
a raccontarsela fino fino a fino allo
scenario più tragico sono un enorme fan
di questa metodologia di lavoro e non mi
immagino certo quando quando parlavo
della situazione di oggi e mela figurava
non mi immagino certo che tutti quanti
arrivano allegramente e io sto sul
materassino perché sono sfigata
io mi immagino che mentre tutti i rem
hanno allegramente io sto sul
materassino al largo con il sale lenti a
contatto per essere già pronta dovesse
capitarmi di stare veramente al largo di
stare veramente sul materassino sgonfia
di stare veramente con
il sale nelle lenti a contatto se
prendiamo queste espressioni come
simboliche mi serve per per sentirmi già
pronta a farmela nuoto non di certo
perché voglio buttarmi giù o voglio non
raccontarmi il finale
io voglio indugiare nella parte della
complicazione perché voglio pensare a
tutte le soluzioni possibili
mi piace proprio quel momento lì in cui
nella mia testa si accendono centinaia
di lampadine e penso a centinaia di
soluzioni non mi sarei immaginata di
essere capace di farmela eventualmente
al nuoto se non mi fossi immaginata il
materassino che poi è quello che ho
appena fatto adesso oggi insieme a voi
per cui vi ringrazio e sono contenta di
non avervi dovuto neanche mentire alla
fine quindi grazie
[Applauso]